this I think
[Laughter]
is
you
[Laughter]
t
check um there is
[Laughter]
WI
always
the look a
little
presenting now be the
time
I would
love
Che
working
can
you need a
you
long
matter
all
right
you
all
I
get
send
[Laughter]
Cod
be
ch
I want
tokik
Joe
help
Ann
we want to speak send
[Laughter]
m
[Applause]
[Laughter]
person one last note our sponsor slice
is not here
[Laughter]
tonight support business and like
pizza so thank you
[Laughter]
here
and
[Laughter]
else
that I'm very to our new speaker first
ever
Lear
[Laughter]
you
like thank you Jared it's wonderful to
see so people here and to see some faes
including from the D2 study group
Jared's right last summer uh during the
international conference on machine
learning I had this idea sitting there
one of their lectures wow it seems this
is collaboration that creates a lot of
great ideas and here and maybe I need to
have people to collaborate with so I
stood up from that corner and I was kind
of nervous I was like this is probably
really stupid thing you're doing just
just
uh like now when jar was like job
announcements I was like a job
announcement uh and a dozen people uh
came up afterward on the initial email
list now there's about 30 people show up
regularly and of are in the
room so it's great very full circle so
let's talk about
it we are going to talk about Machine
Vision and biological Vision as a case
study of how those two systems have Co
evolved we're going to talk about the
building blocks the hardware and the
software that you need to build your own
deep learning
algorithms we won't go too deep into any
Theory but just enough to give you a
sense of the
applications and then we'll talk about
the big ones convolutional neural
networks
lstms what we do at uh untapped my CEO
is here in the corner it's great and uh
deep reinforcement learning as
well so let's start with the case study
of biological artificial Vision so this
guy is a
tri 543 million years
ago some Tri up there developed the
ability to see it a distance and this
created an explosion in speciation all
of a sudden uh trites were able to
detect food and mates in danger at a
distance and then of course prey and
predators have to evolve as well and so
some biologists theorize that that
specific event led to this explosion in
biodiversity that we've seen since uh
the development of happened
in fast forwarding quite a bit hubel
were uh posts at Harvard who were trying
to
identify how the much more complex
brains of mammals
humans relative to chares how these more
complex brains take visual imagery and
make sense of it they were recording
electrical signals from single neurons
in the visual cortex back of a c brain
or your brain so the signal comes from
your eyeballs goes straight through your
head to the back and they were showing
pictures of cats and fish and they
weren't getting any neurons that were
firing by accident as they moved one of
the slides out of the way they noticed
that the edge of the slide caused firing
in one of these neurons so what this
here illustrates is that very specific
orientations so these are orientations
of the bar being shown to the path and
you can see here that this 45° angle
elicits a much greater
response than even close by
orientations and like many things in
statistics this fits the normal
distribution so what they discovered was
that these in the visual cortex V1 you
have these very simple edges being
detected and then those feed up into
layers further forward in your brain
that represent no longer just straight
lines but uh corners and more complex
shapes so for example in our human brain
we have the V1 cortex that I was just
describing that detects edges and then
moving further up those edges merge to
form more complex shapes to detect form
motion we have an area called the Fus
form face area that has evolved
specifically to detect other human
faces in the Machine
World the first attempts to
replicate visual scenery uh came quite a
bit after the tri when Leonardo D Vinci
invented the camera
of the first attempt to have machines
understand the visual World well the
first well documented ort Le was the
lock World which lry Roberts um came up
with where he was trying to detect these
relatively simple structures with
Machine
Vision the first productionize Machine
Vision algorithm was this one developed
by Biola and Jones in 2001 and it
captures The prominent thinking of the
time which was that you need to
explicitly code in features that
algorithms need to understand faces
houses boats whatever you'd have to come
up with some clever algorithm to
identify that object so VI and Jones
algorithm specifically was these black
and white bands so they had two of them
in particular that
tended to indicate with the high
statistical probability the Pres of case
so this algorithm was simple enough it
was the first one to go in production it
went into Canon phones some years after
2001 when the initial paper was
published and you all here probably
remember when all of a sudden phones
started finding faces automatically as
you were taking the photo and focused on
that an alternative to that feature
specific way of analyzing
or algorithmically
identifying or what have you
is a biologically inspired approach
so one of the first of its kind was
Fukushima in 1980 with his neurocog so
he was inspired by's cat experiments and
so he coded together an algorithm it was
layers of neurons taking in simple edges
and gradually having more complex um
features represented at each
stage now there were some key things
missing for him one he didn't have very
much data and two he was missing
something called back propagation
algorithm which we'll get into later so
this largely didn't work but it was a
conceptual
idea the first time this kind of
approach a deep neural net approach in
fact uh went into production was by U so
yon Lon he's here he was here at NYU for
a long time and now quite famously
leading a very large Facebook AI
research team at NYU and yosa Benjo was
was and still is leading a large Lab at
the University of
Montreal so they published this paper
where they were looking at Nest digits
and we're going to talk about these a
lot in my talk so these are handwritten
digits uh there are 70,000 of them in
the data set half of them were WR by US
Postal Service workers and the other
half were written by school children
so thetically split into 60,000 training
digits and 10,000 digits left over for
testing your
algorithm we'll get into more detail
later but just to quickly give you a
sense of what's Happening Here on the
left side of the input of this network
the raw digits are read in as pixels and
then through these feature Maps the
representations be increasingly complex
and at the end of the network is out
some probability of whether this is a
zero one or two or a
three
who
right
so so this illustrates kind of so you
have the raw digit going in and then the
first layer is kind of detecting edges
and then deer in the network it's
detecting more features of Digit three
until at the end it says I think this is
a
three after that
application there was a winter in AI
research people I a coworker told me to
make a coming J and I told him it was
G uh
so there was there there was a um an
incredible reduction in funding uh the
Canadian government was one of the few
places that continued to fund research
in neural networks people who were
publishing in that space uh had to
publish with code words
basically hope that
works
so the Canadian government contined to
fund this uh research people who were
publishing it had to publish it in uh
code words if they wanted to get it
published in any prominent uh computer
science journals and that's why today we
still see a lot of This research coming
out of University of Al the University
of Toronto and University of
Montreal that might keep
happening
uh the big change that has all of us
talking talking about people today was
the imet competition so what happens in
this competition is that it's a very
large data set created by and her
colleagues at Stanford University it has
14 million images in it that were
labeled by people on Amazon Mechanical
Turk
and uh they're in 22,000 different image
categories so you see a sense of eight
of the sample images here so here's a
picture of containership the human
annotator and
as a container and then this is the
output from some deep learning algorithm
it's estimating that uh the mostely
thing black bar this is a conip second
guess is that this is a light Bo for
images that are more ambiguous like this
might you can see it confidence is lower
and it's less sure but this is
definitely over being a black widow and
in some instances it's
wrong technically but you might say that
the human annotator was wrong for
example the anator gave this image
Cherry it g with very strong probability
dation and it's hard to fault the
algorithm same thing here convertible
Grill so in
2012 Jeffrey Hinton and his team at the
University of
Toronto on a team led by
Alexy they submitted a deep learning
algorithm so it was the first time that
one had been Ed into this competition so
you can see in 2010 2011 the error rates
were about 27
25% with traditional um explicitly coded
feature approaches as we were describing
earlier and then in 2012 with this deep
learning approach it blew them out of
the water so we went from a 25% air rate
to a 16% air rate and you can see that
the uh the airor rates continue to fall
all with deep learning algorithm shown
in purple to the extent that in 2015 it
eclipsed human performance on this
path to illustrate that another way this
axis is the other way so this is
accuracy rate as opposed to error rate
but you can see that algorithm by Alexi
and Jeff Hinton in 2012 is here the
learning approach and since then all of
the best approaches have been deeping
mon so here's a look at algorithm AL C
so it's effectively identical to the
structure we saw on the in
1998 the big differences
were they had access to powerful
gpus they had access to way more label
training
data and Compu in
general
um yeah so that would need that's it's a
different cable but they might have one
those
try
um it'll have to look at my face an
awkward black
pauses so that one it seems
periodic
right
so
so like we were describing earlier with
the digits and like the biological
Vision you can see that in the earliest
layers the network is detecting edges
and blogs and then as we move deeper
into the network these are turned into
more complex textures object parts and
then at the end um it's actually make
guesses about the
categories so today
so from 2012 when je B image competition
under the water to today we're now
seeing deep Nets everywhere so
Facebook's face tagging and suggestion
that's a deep learning algorithm Tesla
is self-driving cars deep learning
algorithms Google inboxes suggested
replies the tremendous increase in the
voice recognition performance on Siri on
your Apple devices that's deep learning
as well so it's everywhere now that's
it's happening more and
more one of the most fun implementations
I found algorithm was this film sunsing
where they fed uh hundreds of
Blockbuster film scripts into um an lstm
type model we talking to in the last
section and um they made with
it so
won't show too much of this but it's
quite
amusing and you won't be able to hear
the audio oh nice one sec we're GNA do a
quick uh video change up
here let's see how this
goes all right we'll try that out
completely un
compon so we have audio on this so I
won't show long but you should I I
recommend watching this at home it's
pretty funny big name actors in it a lot
of production
value and doing really random things
that the lsdm them to
do
so the
um
kind of you know kind of classic things
that you see in movies all added
together none of the dialogue makes any
sense but all of the words next to each
other
do so quite a bit
random any
uh so you can watch that on your own
time so you want to build your own movie
script what do you need to
know so with respect to Hardware you can
do a lot of these things on your local
machine particularly for testing things
out you can build your own
server uh you can use aw or Google Cloud
platform if you're doing anything with
your own server or in the cloud you
definitely want to be using gpus to get
anything meaningful out of your analysis
it's it's amazing how much faster uh
time work wow it might not be
me and then Google is soon to be
releasing their tensor processing units
which are GPU specifically configured
for these kinds of operations although
today they don't have them at all um
they paid us $100,000 to migrate over
them they don't have gpus for us at all
so if from Google wants to give us
access to gpus on your private Alpha
please talk to me
afterward so there are four major
libraries that everyone's using
forste these are
Cafe torch Fano and tlow
so Cafe F and tensible you can call them
all from
tython Lua is
is is the only kind of obscure uh Choice
here for pre-trained models basically
all of them offer some kind of
compatibility but Cafe and torch have
the best and I'll talk about the cafe
one later in talk if you want to be
parallelizing your um aspects
parallelizing data processing over
multiple gpus all four languages support
that
however t is by far the best for
splitting up your modeling over multiple
gpus so bear that in mind if you're
doing any very large
analysis the problems with tensor flow
and piano are that you can really get a
good look into source code whereas you
can with C
porch with respect to RNN the natural
language processing technique by far the
best is tlow in piano is okay that and
then if you want to be calling these
languages with a higher level API and
we'll discuss those in detail in the
talk uh car is your best bet for getting
either theow but the easiest language
for sure is TF learn and we'll go
through some examples um
shortly finally uh my website john.com
resources I maintain um a list of the
great resources for getting started in
the space and as sh mentioned we also
run a deep learning study group um so
get in touch with me if you're
interested in that we're trying to keep
it relatively small but would also be
great to have um more
people
so with respect to Theory let's talk
about the building block of artificial
networks so uh so artificial neural
networks are modeled off of biological
neurons so the way that biological
neurons work is they have thousands of
dendrites inputting into a single cell
body and then the cell body get positive
or negative
changes affected by those all those
inputs and then if the charge changes
past a specific threshold then a binary
output a charge is down along the Aon to
further neurons later on in the neuron
network of your
brain the perceptron created
by person
Paul 1957 is following the same kind of
idea so it has multiple inputs as many
as you like from either your values or
parts of the network feeding into some
kind of calcul
and if that calculation is say above a
threshold then the outut a binary output
is zero or one
and and so that mirrors the binary
action potential that we see in
biological
neurons um the problem with this kind of
binary
output is
that sorry no no
worries I actually have a perfect M talk
here I can turn my laptop
around so the problem with these kind of
binary outputs is that once you start I
think that's a more once you start
stacking these perceptrons together
it's very difficult to have any kind of
learning happen with the network because
small changes in your inputs have these
large binary outputs on neurons within
the
network so therefore have this not
effect through the network into the
output so just makes it difficult to
have any kind of um subtle learning
happen a solution is to instead of
having the binary from neurons you have
now this no longer really represents any
of biological concept but you have use
Sig shape so you take the same kind of
function we had in that um in the in the
Peron the binon and wrap it in function
like the sigmoid function or t function
the only difference being the sigo runs
from Z to one run from one to
one slightly different curve
shape but the state of art today is to
be using rectified linear units or leaky
rectified linear units which despite
having less um subtlety as a curve they
are far easier to do computations on
faster compliations on rather and so
having more units as opposed to fewer s
t neurons is faster and more efficient
overall so let's talk about Ching me
single together
Network you can but I already
dangerously have too much content so is
a fast
question yeah go
ahead
well so those extrema actually are a
problem for learning because learning
the gradient at the extremes is very
slow so that's actually not an it's
actually it's
actually well that's interesting
I mean this is probably okay let's see
what we can do
here yeah we're all
good
where we right here
so when we're changing these networks
together into a neural
network a great example for talking this
digits which I already described briefly
so 60,000 handwritten digits to train on
and 10,000 more to test
on each of the images
is is 28 by
28 so a very simple way of thinking
about these is you can just flatten out
images into 784 pixels and you can feed
those 784 pixels into a simple network
with for example here 15 hidden layers
this is called the fully connected
single hidden layer Network this is a
shallow architecture where you
have every single neuron in the input
layer connecting to every single neuron
in the hidden layer and then every
single neuron in the hidden layer
connects forward into the outut layer
the output layer corresponds to 10
outputs each representing one of the 10
possible
digits so to illustrate how that kind of
thing
works I have this really fun demo so
here's a really simple network uh we're
trying to solve this classification
problem where blue dots are a positive
one positive cases and orange dots are
negative
cases and here's a very simple neural
network one hidden layer and one
neuron you can see kind of how these
things work where we can therefore only
put a linear classifier through if we
have two neurons then you can have two
linear classifiers interact so that's
the best you can do if you add more
in uh the interaction can become more
complex if you change the activation
from to Val it has an increase in
performance the shape changes slightly
and I think it's become far too easy to
do this simple classification task so
let's give it let's throw a harder one
at
it now to solve this kind of problem
that's simple Network we putting
together possibly going to be able to
come the calculation and do it but I was
playing around with quite a few
configurations of this earlier I'm sure
a lot would learn but I this one is
pretty
fast really cool thing is that all this
is implemented in JavaScript in your
local your local
browser so you can see here and this is
something we'll talk about in a few
different ways the training loss is
shown in Gray is the loss on your on the
sa on the training data which the dig is
the 60,000 training test uh training
samples and the test
data is the is the H step unseen data
you can see this points very well and it
learns this quite obscure shape by like
the biological networks we looking at
taking these um these
edges turning them into more complex
representations like um uh like
circles and then in the final layer
um you know creating these very complex
representations and you can see these uh
these lines represent the weight the
strength of the connection between a
neuron in one layer the next this gives
you a sense of how
these so in demo I went from shallow
arure with layer to a deep layer with
multiple hidden layers it's represented
by a diagram like this once again this
is a fully connected net
where all the one connect to
one so to demonstrate how you might
implement this in code specifically
we're going to look at a couple of TF
learn
examples so I buil a notebook
here which you can access from my
slid and so it's fairly
simple uh you import the library you
import the M
data and you assign it into uh test and
and training
sets and then you specify the parameters
of the network you're looking for so you
have to Define an input layer to take in
those 784 pixels for each image then we
have a fully connected layer a drop a
layer which talk about later to
regularize so that um applicable to more
broader set of data and we just do the
same thing again so we have fully
connected layer drop out second fully
connected layer and drop out and then a
softmax layer we'll see that throughout
this talk that's just a way
of of picking from the 10 possible digit
outputs and assigning a probability that
so this is the whole network right here
very simple very small amount of code
with one layer feeding into the
next make sense
right and uh then you assign you tell it
you know what how you want to learn so
using stochastic to sent
and then it it run the optimizer and
this wouldn't have taken very long just
a few minutes even on my local machine
and it had 99% classification accuracy
on digits if you were willing to take
its top three
guesses so the way these algorithms work
is probably using another biological
analogy when you're born you have far
more connections AB between all your
neurons than you do as an adult so you
kind of start with like this large
neural network of connections and
randomly initialize weight between those
connections just like you do artificial
Network then in your early years as you
start to learn the importance of your
mother's voice and your dad's face or
what food you like the connections some
of the connections are strengthened and
many of them are Prov way
to what we do with our
networks most content slide
yeah this is actually me when I
was so I'm go to any of the details of
stochastic desent that's you know
someone can do full lecture on that
someday but there's a specific
implementation of atom that people
typically use today in many deing
algorithms and this is just a way it's
just a way of minimizing whatever cost
defined so whatever you're trying to
minimize what you're learning it's learn
byas the um something that's unique to
deep learning approaches that was
developed in the 80s and makes it work
so well is back propagation so back
propagation is I feel I should just
more oh nice well I can talk about back
seconds for
sure
so just remember the little demon in
there in the middle of that
so uh what back propagation enables you
to do is it enables you to to look at
you feed an image into the network or
set of images into the network and then
you have some assessment of the
performance how well the network was
able to classify that image and where
the weight were correct weren't and what
back propagation enables you to do is to
very quickly pass through all the layers
of your network and figure out what
small adjustments might be able to be
made to take a step in the direction of
classifying correctly on image so uh
basically the way that these networks
learn is it's just a constant path back
and forth of input an image send the
weights through the network that that
that that input creates evaluate whether
the output was correct or not and if it
was not correct that back propagate back
through all the layers of your network
figuring out what small adjustments you
can tune along the way to step towards a
better
model wow didn't notice that happening
behind
me
so um does anyone have questions now be
a great time yes
excellent question um it's it's very
difficult to know how many hidden layers
you should have um you can learn a lot
faster with with
child
so uh
because layers um so if you have a very
very large Network say it has 100 layers
in it which is would pretty
stateoftheart for you with 100 layers
that the very early layer the first
layer the second layer they're very far
from the image that is trying to be
classified correctly or not and so those
so the layers that are very close to
that image the stochastic descent or
whatever Optimizer you're using can kind
of can be more helpful at that end but
then very deep layers all the signals
kind of lost through that
so you kind of want to start with a
shallow Network there are
only very specific cases where you want
to have a very deep Network um you might
want to think about it kind of
anecdotally relative to the complexity
of the images you're looking at so if
you were for example only trying to
classify edges you only want one
layer that
happens
nice so
overfitting of course when you have so
many parameters when you have
potentially millions of neurons in
network and billions it's amazing it's
some kind of interaction of my machine
with
that
I
yeah so should I like reset my
laptop how much what do the audience
want me to do should I try resetting my
laptop
keep okay doesn't bother me so the
problem with having so many weights in a
network is that you could very easily
overfit so you know if you're trying to
this simple Parabola and you're doing it
with a with a linear classifier uh it's
not going to fit as well it's a
parabolic function then if you add in
you know n or 10 parameters in your
model you can fit it perfectly but it's
not going to generalize well so L1 and
L2 regularization are very
approaches we see throughout machine
learning that also work in that's drop
is unique approach where you
arbitrarily on each round of
your you drop out uh some set say half
of the neurons at random and then next
learning you a different half and that
enables generalization to happen um much
better or you could expand your data set
so with the m digits you could take the
original digits and turn them all you
know
slightly there's no way time to go
through any of these in detail but there
are a set
of a set of ways you can go about
improving your networks and I wrote a
summary blog post
here for doing that so you can get that
link to the slides I'm a
stage so it goes step by step through
how you can
work
better and one of the Beautiful Things
is you can prove that any continuous
function can be solved by neural nwork
so whatever problem you can you can fix
this we talk about briefly with your
question so basically you have this
Vanishing gradient as networks get
deeper becomes harder and harder to
train the lower uh the earliest layers
in the network what this is showing is a
logarithmic decrease in your ability to
train so the learning rate in Hidden
layer one over training box is two or of
magnitude lower than in the fourth layer
and as you added more layers that Trend
continues so it's become quite a state
of game to be able to add layers that
you network at all so we talked about
Alex winning the competition in
2012 in uh 2014 the runner up with an IM
called BG and it was Google in 2014 and
they won with networks with layers of 8
19 and 22 and that was stateof thee art
in 2014 the subsequent year Microsoft
research Asia came up with a ret which
circumnavigates by means far beyond the
scope of this talk um the the vanishing
creating problem and so they had a
network with 152 layers and they cut the
accuracy
or the error rate in half as you can
see so we're going to talk about alet
and gole net Alex net and B bget in
detail because they relatively simple so
these are kind of classic architectures
they have only different kinds of layers
in them we have convolutional layers
which are very important to any comp's
machine tasks we haven't talked about
them yet uh and you can you can see Al
is eight layers V here is
and they're basically the same thing
just linear sending your signal through
the network linearly and it goes your
input go convolutional layers A pooling
layer convolutional pooling fully
connected layers we talked of this talk
and then soft is just a determin of the
possible categor which is most
probable and just an extension of that
so they've just taken the same structure
they've added one more fully connected
layer and they've added iterations of
convolutional so to remind you guys
inspired by biology we have the simple
um structures edges being turned into
more complex shapes and that's the same
way that Alex net was working in 2012 as
we discussed already the convolutional
layer specifically is unsurprisingly
important it's called Ms and I'm just to
very briefly talk about them so if you
have an image of a cat and it's now
represented on this block it has three
different um color layers R green blue
and it has a height and WID and what the
convolutions do is they pass filters
that the size of this patch over the
image so it just scans it left to right
bottom to top and it does and several
different neurons do that
simultaneously and each
develop it own kind of specialization
for what it's looking for in the
image nothing do that nothing do better
job illustrating that than this video
so so basically so this is this is
showing the same kind of uh
visualization for the same kind of test
that we beginning where the computional
net is trying to guess what kind of
looking and here guessing 100%
probability that this is a school bus
right now we're looking at one of the
ear layers of the the convolutional L
and you can see it's picking out edges
of the
image so you can see here it'sing 89%
this is a yire terrier I challenge you
guys to distinguish a yire terrier from
Sil
terrier and once again you know this
early layer this conval layer is quite
good at distinguishing edges here it is
Jason skinsky the author of this video
and this Library uh here he is speaking
and my dream one day is to be able to do
a talk using his Library like showing
you guys on screen next
time and so as you move deeper into lay
into the layers of the network more
complex layers so now we're in the fifth
layer here you can see there are more
neurons and just like in the humanin
where we have the F for face area
are neurons specialized to seeing faces
and his body comes into video then it
sees two faces so you can kind of see
how
machines and biology have learned the
same ways of structuring our world which
is cool creepy thing here is recognizing
in shirt so there's a different dra the
face one which you can still see here in
the
middle and this one is recognizing Tex
on books so it's specifically PRI to
that so you have all these different
neurons throughout the network that
become specialized and recognizing
different kind of objects and then the
final layers of fully connected one each
of those objects can be combined
together repres entire image